Hello, there.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, the other day we had
a conversation, didn't we?
Yup.
And I was like, how can
we get two paint balls
to collide mid-air and
film it in slow motion?
My first thought was
we're just gonna stand
opposite each other and just let rip
and then hopefully...
Would never happen.
The accuracy, the timing,
it would never happen.
The pain, as well.
The pain, the fear.
You'd be scared like this.
I've had bad luck with paint balls.
Ooh, that looks like a shot to the mouth.
Gavin, you look like a mess.
Bloody, dead eye rising, blew my face off.
It looks like you have a second mouth.
It's not pleasant.
It's not nice.
So, instead, I've made this contraption
with vice grips and string.
Yeah, I mean, it is a
complex thing for us,
but in the grand scheme of
internet videos, it's very basic.
I mean, there could be like
an electronic button to just do it,
but instead I've just bought two guns
and sort of tried to rig them up
so they're shooting each other.
Okay, so we'll see if we can collide
two paint balls somewhere around here.
I'm gonna have to pre-set
the focus and the framing,
but you know probably about
around there, isn't it?
We'll film it at 28,500
frames a second on the V2511
and if we're feeling a little bit cheeky,
we'll boost that frame rate up.
Juicy.
And see what we can get.
So, somewhere around here, yeah?
Yeah.
Just like, all right.
So, you're just eyeing it.
I mean, it's so minuscule that
I'm gonna try and eye it, yeah.
It's just kind of difficult because
sometimes when you clamp it back up,
it just goes back where it wants.
A little bit of give.
Yeah, there's a bit of give
in the plastic of the gun.
If we had, like a cylindrical rod,
we could just shove it down both barrels.
It's true.
We don't though.
Yeah, if we were more
prepared, it'd be easier.
Let's see how that does.
You ready?
Yeah.
No.
Yup!
That was it?
Yup.
Aw.
What's up?
I think they just bonked.
They hit!
Yeah, they did!
I think they just glanced
each other slightly.
What are the chances of that?
Tell me when you're ready.
Ready.
Yup.
I think that hit.
Whoa!
Did the green one just annihilate it?
The green one survived!
How's that happen?
It's different every time we do it!
It's just like when you
get hit in paint ball
and it doesn't explode.
Is there, like, tape or
something on that paint ball?
No, it's like half of it's got
the branding pattern, I think, on it.
A little bit of the pattern, sort of,
swung off and spun away.
Look.
Oh, yeah.
Frisbee'd it into the distance.
Okay, my first adjustment was too much
and it meant that they just dinked.
So, I've readjusted that time,
and only one of them exploded,
and they weren't quite bang on.
So, this time I've adjusted
again, just a little bit,
and hopefully we'll
get that exact meaty...
A little eek.
Yeah.
A little gnats.
Little eek and gnats.
Gnats.
A gnats kneecap, yeah,
that's the saying, isn't it?
Yeah.
Yup.
That was it?
I think so.
I actually saw the exact second
that they hit each other.
You know when you close your eyes
and you have like freeze-frame and clink?
I captured that perfectly.
I went like, boop, and
I just saw it explode.
Could you send that to me?
Yeah, yeah, hang on.
Send the jpeg.
All right.
I've got airdrop turned on.
Got it.
Man, this camera's loud.
All right, playing back.
Here we go.
Nailed it!
Perfect!
That's amazing!
So, it looks like they hit on the back,
like one is on the front,
one is on the back.
Yeah, just slightly.
Look how they open up, like a fruit.
It's like a physalis or
a kumquat or something.
Yeah, in here it's like juicy
and then it turns into like a spiderweb.
It almost looks like a
nervous system there,
like a lot of neurons.
Yeah, or like a capillaries, or something.
Wonder how much that
actually happens in, like,
real paint ball matches?
It must happen quite a bit.
Is that square on enough?
Or would you want any more adjustments?
That's pretty good.
So satisfying, getting it the first time.
Yeah.
I thought these were made of rubber,
but they're actually made of, like,
plastic that's quite thick.
You can see the difference
in the paint balls.
This one split along the actually--
Is that like, the seal hole?
Yeah, the two different kinds of plastic
that seal the paint in.
And, this one, is just sort
of burst all over the place.
I think these are the more expensive ones.
And, these are the cheaper ones.
Has it run out of gas?
Yeah, we've run out of gas,
so they're sort of flopping out the gun,
instead of firing out.
Me, too.
I need more beans.
Need more beans.
How do you remove it
without it spraying everywhere?
I don't know if you can.
Sweaty hands, eh.
Maybe I haven't run out of gas.
Jesus!
Yup.
Flipping A.
That soaked me!
Sometimes it's hard to tell
when it actually happens.
Yeah, makes you wonder
how many we've missed.
The other one.
Oh, .
That is so satisfying.
It's cool, isn't it?
It's amazing that even though
one comes out way before the other,
they still meet perfectly in focus.
That's so weird.
Is it just that I'm always
pulling one slightly later?
I think so.
I think it's just, there's a slight delay.
So, I'm not--
Well, I mean, even if you do that,
in slow-mo, there's always gonna be
one that goes before the other.
What an operation this is.
I know.
Yup.
Excellent shooting.
Thank you, very much, sir.
Excellent shooting for you, too.
Oh, thanks, thank you very much.
Yeah.
It's so weird, because
there's probably milliseconds
in the difference that
I'm pulling them there,
but in slow-mo, it just looks like an age.
Like, it's halfway to the gun before
the green one even comes out.
Well, let's count.
So, that one's at the end of the barrel
at, well, it's 3:52:33 seconds .104231.
Okay.
So, what's the first number?
That's the tenth of a second.
What's the third number?
1000th.
So, I'm 12 thousandths of a second out?
You should be ashamed of yourself.
Call myself a slow-mo guy.
Made a mess of the board there.
Oh, and the fence over here.
The thing is, I figured that
this fence was further away
so the pattern would be a bit more spread.
How long do you think it would take me
to paint the whole fence
with a paint ball gun?
A week?
Yeah.
Like, solid, if it's going
bang bang bang bang bang.
Wouldn't be very cost effective,
considering all the paint
balls and the CO2 you'd need.
It's be a lot.
I wonder how much that would cost.
It's not very drippy, is it,
and look, it's very powdery.
Look, it's so weird.
Oh!
Every time.
We cannot do a paint ball video
without you doing that.
Didn't get me though, really.
No, just me.
That's unfortunate.
I've meant to have the clean lab coats.
Sorry, it does come off quite easily.
Does it?
Yeah.
Tell you what, the Blue
Man hair didn't come off.
That didn't, did it?
It didn't dry, either.
I think you need a new lab coat.
About a month later.
I should get a new lab coat.
Yeah, you should.
I mean, I need one, but, I don't know.
It's just not in the budget.
Quite like those shots.
Very satisfying to watch.
Just the way the paint spreads
in, sort of, random patterns,
different every time.
I could just watch them collide all day.
Well, sometimes, I couldn't
actually tell if they'd hit.
The only way I could tell was
if there was no noise on
the fence, either side.
Yeah.
Because there would be nothing left of it.
It's just be evisceration--
Well, sometimes they would hit,
but depending on the timing, they'd hit,
sort of, over here and clip, or over here,
but they would nail each other here.
But, it was interesting
because the wood is all ,
jostle-y, and the pressure
from pulling the triggers,
the barrels, as you were
pulling them, were doing that.
So, I'm amazed that
they ever hit each other
because it was like .
I think they just come out so fast
that by the time the barrels
react and move around,
the paint balls already come out.
Like, when you saw with the close-up shot
of the paint ball gun, it came out,
and then it went like whoa.
This time, we didn't shoot each other,
but we still made a video
with paint ball guns.
That's good going.
We're evolving.
We don't always have to hurt each other.
No!
No, although, you did say,
can I shoot you in the face with it?
And I said no.
So.
That wasn't really a serious suggestion.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Ooh!
I got myself with it!
That was a backfire.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys.
We do slow-mo all the time.
And, also, we have a second channel
full of behind-the-scenes
and extra guff.
I think that went in my eye.
That was good!
You didn't get the most of it, there.
Most of it, went flying.
I'm getting good at this, no?
We'll see you in the next video.
Thank for watching.
Gotta wipe down all the equipment.
Oh, it went on the laptop!
Sorry.
Let's go wash off.
Did that go on my face?
Yeah.